[Applause]
nobody's ever looked as good as you
look nobody's ever made me fall the way
I'm falling right
[Music]
now nobody's ever stolen broken my heart
heart the way that you didn't
still just cuz I love you don't mean I
want to just cuz I need you don't mean I
ought to just cuz I feel like I feel
when we kiss don't mean that the pain
isn't as real as it
is just cuz I love
you
it don't mean I want
to come over and hold you lay down
beside you just cuz you're someone I
can't say goodbye
to just cuz I love you don't mean I want
to just cuz I need you don't mean I
ought to just cuz I feel
like I feel when we kiss don't mean that
the pain isn't as real as it
is just cuz I love
you hey don't mean I
[Music]
[Applause]
want
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home